here's how I think the average American
might think about cancel culture uh hey
uh occasionally people get cancelled but
it's mainly uh social media
related um it's not maybe that big a
deal I find it uh
unlikable uh but it's not something I
should be you know staying awake at
night thinking about now your book has a
number of um awesome contributions in it
uh it's a much more rigorous uh
cataloging shall we say of cancel
culture it breaks it down its impacts on
different institutions Ricky you said
that hey that a lot of this is still on
campuses which I think is where most
people think of it so let's start at
campuses why why are college campuses
such a fertile ground for what we'd
consider cancel culture and for a moment
for people how would you define cancel
culture so I think that campuses are
really fertile ground for cancel culture
because you show up you're young you
want to fit in and often times there's a
very loud liberal minority of students
who are tying people's viewpoints to
their their personal status or who they
are as human beings and and very
indulgent in these ad hominum attacks
and we attack people on social media and
when you're a kid that shows up and
you're afraid of putting yourself out
there and you think that like I did I
was hiding books under my bed like
Jordan Peterson and Thomas soul you
really feel as though you can't put
yourself out there and I learned the the
kind of going off jumping off the cliff
and writing for the New York Post and
saying here are my viewpoints and I
think that free speech is a problem on
campus which was my first major oped all
the people around me felt the same way
or the vast majority I had people coming
out of every crevice of of Roommates of
um deans of of uh like whole departments
and professors that I had who would come
to me quietly and say oh I I completely
agree with you and good on you for
writing about free speech on campus but
just don't tell anyone that we had this
conversation and so I think there's
something about that highly ideological
bubble that really lets this go arai and
where those really aggressive loud
people who tear people down who use bias
response hotlines because the
Administration has just put this whole
bureaucracy around cancel culture and
basically indulging it it's it's the
tyranny of the minority just goes crazy
in real life in the same way that I
think it does in social media and then
in like the liveaction version on
college campuses essentially so Greg how
would you define cancel culture you it
sounds like you have a a technical
definition yeah I I I do have I do it
Ben this is the one of the few times
I'll sound like a lawyer but I want to
be precise about it and it's the uptick
beginning around 2014 and accelerating
in 2017 uh and after of campaigns to get
people fired disinvited deplatformed or
otherwise punished for speech that is or
would be protected by the First
Amendment and the climate of fear and
Conformity that has resulted from this
uptick um because I'm trying to make
clear that we're not talking about
something that's strictly partisan
although the term cancel culture is
often times you know something that
people will accuse the left of being
guilty of and and certainly that's true
to a large degree uh but we also take on
cancel culture from the right because
what we saw after 2014 and it wasn't
subtle it was just suddenly people were
rather than just being really
embarrassed on on Twitter or or Facebook
they were losing their jobs um for you
know jokes that that went viral for
example um and on campus uh one of the
reasons why it is just so frustrating
that there are still people you know
trying to claim this doesn't this
happening the uptick in professors
getting cancelled is unlike anything
we've seen in the modern era of higher
education I mean the law protecting
academic freedom was and and free speech
on campus wasn't really clear until
about 19 1973 and there hasn't been a
period like this in that entire time
when this many professors are getting
you know fired tenured professors in
many cases for what they say what they
print uh What uh what they um and having
their research
uh that that getting in trouble and some
actually having withdrawn which is which
is usually considered an extraordinary
measure one of the goals of of the piece
was to of the book was to put it all in
one place and and try to give some
historical comparisons like when you
talk about uh sometimes people have no
it's very funny watching people don't
really know anything about the history
of freedom of speech claim oh these are
you know no these are tiny numbers the
it's not significant but when you're
talking about over a thousand professors
targeted you know um just in the last
nine and a half years since canel
culture began with about two-thirds of
those punished with uh with about one of
those about almost 200 fired you're
talking about numbers that blow away
even things like the Red Scare where
where the normal estimates about a 100
professors you know were fired and and
at the time everyone knew the Red Scare
was happening like that that a lot of
that research actually comes it was
contemporaneous with it so it's been a I
try not to use this word too often but
it's been a a crisis on campus um and
and yeah we point out when about about a
third of those punishments um come from
usually the off-campus right and we call
those out uh as well but I do want it at
the same time I remember saying this to
somebody on on social media I'm like
well but I thought of them come from
conservatives like but you're implying
that the the rest come from the left and
it's like well yeah you you don't think
there's a free speech problem on on the
left on Camp like that that's that's
just is willful blindness at this point
yeah and I might add that on the on the
rightwing cancel culture um kind of side
of things this is something that like I
know I'm going to take a lot of flak for
from some people that might otherwise um
like what I write about and stuff but I
have absolutely no problem calling out
what I see as ill fighting illiberalism
with illiberalism and fighting might
with might in a really disturbing way
because there's like a wide opening for
for people and leaders to step in and
say Free Speech has been largely
abdicated as a a major principle of the
left and here we are going to actually
step in and adopt that rather than fight
that hot mess that's happening in the
radical leftwing with our own author
Arian hot mess on the right which is
just super disappointing to me and I I
think that there's such a lack of a a
positive restorative road map to like
how how can one one side or no side or
just a group of people in the center or
people who just are actually classical
liberals reclaim those values and it
feels as though that's not a
conversation that happens often enough
and it's like oh we're the champions of
free speech on the right but then here
are all our very authoritarian bills
that actually curb free expression at
the same time it's it gets my blood
boiling hey YouTube glad you're enjoying
the podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank
you